what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and this is uh episode
three four
maybe even five
of the podcast um i've had a really good
time doing it so far we've had some
really good guests on but uh it's just
gonna be me today hope everybody's okay
with that um but we have a lot to talk
about a lot to talk about i saw thor 11
thunder at the world premiere on
thursday so i'll kind of give you a
quick little reaction uh as to how he
felt about the movie and we have some
news about deadpool in the mcu we're
getting more and more news about
deadpool which is really great which
means he's coming pretty soon they're
working uh sounds like they're working
pretty hard on that script and getting
everything in production uh fantastic
four of course we have a really cool
doom doctor doom easter egg confirmed by
marvel actually by marvel studios
president kevin feige which is really
really exciting
and we're gonna talk about the x-men
because
looks like they're kind of getting
a lot closer to coming into the mcu as
well so a lot to talk about um if you're
listening on a podcast platform apple
music spotify be sure to follow if
you're watching on youtube be sure to
subscribe we talk about awesome marvel
and superhero content so the first thing
i want to talk about is thor love and
thunder um
it's a big one to me because i think the
regular viewers of the channel and the
podcast know that thor is my favorite
character of marvel
i really really love thor
i've i've always really liked him um i
actually like the first couple of thor
films right a lot of people don't
and i i get it it's fine but i enjoyed
them i'm not saying they're you know the
best thing ever
and ragnarok is on a completely
different level and i understand that
but i love ragnarok it's top
it's probably my third favorite marvel
film
under infinity war and end game and if
we don't count those it's probably my
first uh it's it's up there so going
into
thor love and thunder i did what you're
not supposed to do i went in with very
high expectations it's a taikuati it's
chris hemsworth it's basically you know
the same cast the same people and then
you add natalie bartman as
the mighty thor like in my mind i'm like
this is gonna be thor ragnarok plus
the mighty thor and it's gonna be
awesome and it was it was really awesome
um
i can't the review embargo hasn't lifted
yet so i can't really say you know
intricate details and don't worry of
course i won't spoil anything but as far
as my reaction to it i loved it
i really did i don't know if i loved it
more than ragnarok because i have to
watch it again ragnarok is a film that
i've watched many many times and i've
picked it apart
picked many different scenes apart as to
why i really love the movie
and i haven't had a chance to do that
with love and thunder yet i've only seen
it one time at the premiere but
i i thought it was hilarious i laughed
so much and ever every joke delivered um
so i for those worried that it was going
to be too many jokes i i wouldn't worry
some might think so but i laughed every
time and i cried um
there were some touching moments some
sad moments like
it's
it's a film like it's a heck of a film
it's a heck of a movie it's definitely
one of my favorite marvel films and um
really like i felt so many different
emotions
throughout the film like i was reacting
in many different ways i
i laughed i cried
i was invested
there are some serious parts where
you're just on the edge of your seat
like it's an awesome movie it's an
awesome movie and uh you know again you
have to see it again before
like ranking it right one out of
everyone always wants me to like rank it
one out of ten i have to see it again
but um
definitely go see the movie um i think
if you enjoyed ragnarok you are going to
love this movie and if you didn't i
still hope you love this movie because
it's very creative
and i think it's very well put together
and i'll just say this christian bale
amazing
blew me away i i most of the times when
i'm on the edge of my seat was because
of him and natalie portman
she's fantastic so go see the mood go
see it i think uh everybody will at
least
get some laughs out of it and enjoy it
at least a little bit and i think a lot
of people are gonna love it so
go see that movie and uh i want to jump
into this
for at first after my reaction because i
i'm really really excited about this
we'll talk more about this in just a bit
but first thank you to manscape for
sponsoring this video many of you have
probably heard me talk about manscape
before big fan of their products and the
confidence that comes with being
properly groomed you seem to have a
better aura a better vibe you just kind
of carry yourself better manscaped has
always been the leader in below the
waist grooming but now with the platinum
package 4.0 you can trust manscaped with
a lot more in the platinum package 4.0
you'll find your normal awesome manscape
products like the lawnmower 4.0 body
trimmer and the weed whacker nose and
ear hair trimmer featuring the
proprietary advanced skin safe
technology so where you don't nick your
skin both of which are also waterproof
you also get the crop preserver
anti-chafing ball deodorant the crop
reviver ball spray toner but now you
also get ultra premium body wash ultra
premium two in one shampoo plus
conditioner and ultra premium deodorant
to tackle your other hygiene needs and
they even throw in two free gifts
anti-chafing boxers and the shed travel
bag get 20 off and free shipping with
the code cosmic manscape.com that's 20
off with free shipping at manscape.com
and use code cosmic to get all you need
to unlock your big groomed energy
marvel's essentially
confirmed that john cruz um
whoops okay spoiler multiverse of
madness if you haven't seen it yet now
i'm going to jump in so marvel's
basically confirmed
john krasinski's mr fantastic in the
multiverse of madness confirmed his
connection to dr
doom i'll tell you what this article
says and this is pretty cool because
it's it's coming from kevin feige
it's coming from the crew
over at marvel in a recent interview
this was said it's so funny that kevin
feige cast john krasinski because the
fans had a dream of who the perfect reed
richards would be and because this is an
alternate universe i think kevin said
let's make that dream come true i've
always really enjoyed all of his
performances so
right away
that's kind of cool to hear right
it's an alternate universe
it matters in the movie but it
ultimately you know doesn't really
matter as much as uh you know a real mr
fantastic casting would even though i i
do hope and i think a lot of people do
hope that he is the main
uh mr fantastic and
at this point i think it is going to be
uh i i think he is going to be but
we'll move on from that but it's really
cool that
kevin took that opportunity to say let's
kind of give the fans what they want
in a kind of fanfare way but at the same
time it worked perfectly right because i
do think he's the perfect casting but um
goes on to say reed richards is my
favorite marvel comics character so it
was a real honor to get to write his
first entry in the mcu john such an
amazing performer and such a great
partner in bringing this role to life
for the first time
and i believe this is coming from
michael waldron the writer
says michael waldron made it very clear
how reed richards is his favorite marvel
comic character and getting to write the
character's first mcu appearance was a
real honor he said
it's exciting that costume design by
ryan
mynerdin i'm sorry i definitely did not
pronounce it right
but the costume design is really a
special treat the detail of the
teleportation device he used to get into
the scene is something we took from the
comics
that's dr doom's time platform which is
really really interesting because a lot
of people were comparing
this to actually kang's
technology from the tva and depending on
which story that you read in marvel
comics kang is either related to
doctor doom or reed richards it it
there's two different versions right
there's some retconning there
so that's kind of cool because you could
like either way you can link it to king
but here they're basing it off of dr
doom's time platform
which is really really cool and i'll put
a picture of that so this is our first
doom easter egg
in the mcu
confirmed
by people over at marvel studios
which is
which is really freaking cool
it's it's really
really cool to see and again we still
have that kang connection
and i
i'm gonna say there were some things
that were left
in this movie
unfinished on purpose like if you
realized mourinho's still alive
he's kind of trapped down in that little
pit area or you know in front of the
illuminati but mordo's still alive
so
what's his deal is he gonna come and
seek revenge
is he gonna you know that's kind of more
those thing right he's the doctor
strange enemy so is he gonna try to jump
to our universe now and seek revenge and
is he gonna you know bring with him the
invisible woman
and uh
his son franklin richards who is you
know an omega level mutant and try to
destroy the scarlet witch and destroy
stephen strange there's so much
potential there right especially if this
is truly the multiverse saga
there's so much they could do there so
much they could do there and there's
been a lot of rumors recently that doom
is heading to the mcu sooner than later
possibly in wakanda forever
he could possibly be seeking out some
vibranium and we know that name war is
going to be the villain of what kind of
forever but we also know that namor is
also a hero in marvel comics uh he's
actually a part of the illuminati in
marvel comics so
is it gonna be kind of like the batman
vs superman or any kind of movie where
it's like you know
something versus something where it's
like oh they fight each other but then
it's like oh there's this bigger threat
up there right
is that what we're in for
you know it's going to be wakanda versus
you know neymar and atlantis or whatever
it may be but then it's like oh wait
hold on here's doom right
we have to unite because there's
something bigger and better out there
right maybe this is obviously just
rumors and not confirmed in any way but
i
definitely hope that dr doom is
connected to this in some way shape or
form uh in wakanda forever i i think it
makes perfect sense that he would be
looking for some vibranium whether
that's because he wants to build a
spaceship out of it or or or something
right
i think it's a i think it's a good
opportunity to to connect there so
that's a really cool easter egg for dr
doom and it's cool that they're thinking
about doctor doom
even if it is in an alternate universe
so
yeah i'm really excited about that now
moving on to double three something i'm
just so excited for it like i'm i can't
tell you how excited i am for deadpool
3. ryan reynolds is deadpool
i think there are you know a few
characters that you can say you know
this person is this character it's like
you know robert downey jr is iron man uh
chris hemsworth's door
deadpool is
i mean ryan reynolds is deadpool right
he he made this character live action
it's pretty much just him right
so it's really cool that recently
we've had ton of news about deadpool 3
about how the writers
are hard at work
production has basically begun ryan
reynolds has met with marvel studios
many times uh kevin feige of course is
producing the film with ryan reynolds
producing it as well um ryan
really is working really really hands-on
with this and uh recently we found out
a tiny bit of the storyline a tiny bit
of the plot
um
writer rhett rhys gave us kind of our
first clue um
he was on the post credit podcast
and this is what he said
about the plot he said it's a wonderful
opportunity for fish out of water
deadpool is a lunatic at the center of a
movie to drop a lunatic into a very sane
world it's straight butter it's going to
be really fun so
what does that mean well i think we all
know that
deadpool is kind of a lunatic right that
that part's a given but
he's going to be a fish out of water and
he's going to be dropped into a very
sane world now that's the mcu
right we know that deadpool is making
his way to the mcu
and that's exciting right that's why it
is so exciting now because
not that anything was off limits before
he could he breaks the fourth wall right
he can joke about anything he wants he
can joke about batman right he can say
are you from the dc universe right he
can say whatever he wants but now he's
going to be shoved into our universe
where everything is going to be right in
his face right everything that's
happened so far the the snap you know
thanos everything's going to be right in
his face and he can do whatever he wants
whatever he wants
like really like i think and you can
make fun of the old fox universe right
because he's got to get there somehow
i'm excited to see that story
but it looks like they have
pretty much everything that they need
right now or they have created
everything already for this story they
know what it's going to be so deadpool's
going to be a fish out of water
and i think seeing deadpool as a fish
out of water is going to be very
interesting because maybe he'll care but
i think eventually he just won't and
will just do whatever he wants to do and
that includes i think messing with other
superheroes that's what i'm most excited
to see him interact with other
superheroes i hope we get spider-man i
think tom holland would love to be
in deadpool 3. it's just kind of up to
the studios at this point
but i think it would be fantastic and it
gets complicated when you consider it
sony as well but you know but uh
yeah i
i know that this is actually coming
sooner than later because of all of this
information that we've got
it looks like
probably within the next two years we do
have
time slots for movies coming from marvel
studios that doesn't have
they don't have
assigned
movies yet
we have the dates
but no movie is attached to them and
these are just movies we're talking
about not like disney plus dates these
are dates for movies
and i'm thinking
deadpool's gonna be one of them now it's
just been confirmed in the thor love and
thunder press conference by kevin feige
himself that marvel studios is going to
be attending san diego comic con we had
some reports that uh marvel studios
wasn't going to be attending that they
were saving a lot of their stuff for uh
d23 but they are attending san diego
comic con and whole h
that sdcc is typically where they
reveal everything right that's where
phase four dropped that's where like all
the big stuff drops so
we're about to get
some pretty big announcements and the
last time
that marvel was at sdcc was 2019 and the
last thing that kevin feige said
was i didn't even have time
to talk about the fantastic four and i
didn't have time to talk about mutants
x-men and he said he confirmed those are
interchangeable people asked him why did
you say mutants and he said i they're
they're the x-men those are
interchangeable words to mem to mean him
to me he said me to him
excuse me um
so i'm hoping since the last time we saw
kevin fighting marvel at sdcc he didn't
have time to talk about the mutants he
didn't have time to talk about the
fantastic four he has time now because
kevin feige has already talked about the
fantastic four in the past couple of
years
um we had our director john watts
who uh has now taken a hiatus
from uh the superhero
genre um he directed the spider-man
homecoming trilogy and now he's taking a
break
he's actually doing something over at
star wars now which is you know also
disney but
um
we had him as a director and now we
don't we are looking for a new director
and according to some rumors marvel
studio is looking for some big names
which i'm excited for i'm really really
excited for
so
i'm hoping we get an announcement for
the fantastic four but since they've
already talked about the fantastic four
and kevin feige hinted at mutants i'm
hoping that really what the big reveal
is is the x-men
now in multiverse of madness we had
professor x we had an actual x-men
so
it's not that big of a stretch to
start to really incorporate our x-men
into the main universe so i'm hoping i'm
praying i'm putting out good vibes into
the universe that something gets
revealed maybe like oh yeah we're gonna
do a
have an x-men in
another movie first right
or just simply saying like the first
x-men is about to come to the mcu it
doesn't have to be an x-men movie
announcement i don't think that's coming
anytime soon
but i would like
some hint that they are going to start
to be you know pushed into the universe
and kevin feige did say
in the next few months which uh
september is d23
and uh in the next few months we have
sdcc he said that we're gonna know
get a hint at what the bigger picture of
the mcu is so
there you go looks like some big reveals
are coming
at sdcc and d23 and
i
i have high expectations not to get
people's hopes up but
based off of what kevin feige said based
off of what we've been hearing
some announcements are coming and i'm
hoping they're x-men i'm hoping they're
for all those untitled movie release
dates that we have i'm hoping that they
get titles and we we get to see a little
bit of what's coming in phase five uh
hopefully fantastic four gets an actual
release date and hopefully the mutants
get teased just a little bit but
who knows what marvel has up their
sleeve uh they typically do
they do it right kevin feige knows what
he's doing i always say in feige we
trust i i'm
not concerned for the future of the mcu
i think they have so much coming up and
um
there's some cool stuff in thor love and
thunder that you kind of go like wow um
can't believe i saw that
and you'll get a cool not a glimpse of
the future but just kind of like a cool
idea of what marvel can do so
go watch lord love and thunder when it
comes out in about two weeks i think
and look out for my videos my podcast on
what to expect from sdcc and d23
especially when it happens i'll be
covering a lot of news from those days
so be sure to subscribe if you haven't
yet or follow whatever platform you're
on and uh i will catch you all next week
thank you all so much for stopping by
woof
me
me